speaking of getting more famous dude is
it crazy how
like I mean we've been around for 20
years you know people recognize us
wherever we go but this last movie
coming out like I really noticed like
the way it's a whole different thing
dude yeah it's like wow we're like we're
we're like because I think the 10-year
Gap
I just notice it a lot and and here's
the thing too that [ __ ] kind of like
it it gets
and since this last movie came out it's
gotten to a point like where it's
actually really difficult to get around
in public because it's like you know
there's it's it's kind of just
overwhelming with like pictures and and
stuff like I don't even know dude and
it's and it's it's it's too uh extent
that like it's impossible to to keep up
with it and it's impossible to not get
like but you know I find myself getting
like grumpy and I [ __ ] hate it man
I'd like to see people in a camera photo
and I'm like put it on cell phones
you're like and I'm like sure I haven't
gotten that short with people but my
lady says I'm like and eating one the
eating one bothers me it I'm not even
joking I think manners have gone away
from people like I'm being serious 100
because I would never go up to somebody
with like their hands on a burger and
like their mouth on it and go hey like
don't even say Hello nice to meet you
anymore that's been long gone where they
sit in the booth next to you you ever
heard that oh and they just stare but no
but hold on yeah but they go look can I
get a photo
anyway
well hold on and then you you're you
know you're like and you feel bad and
I'm like can I finish eating and then oh
okay whatever but then it even comes to
a point where we're like well I'm going
okay well that's your time then bro
sorry yeah right but here's one that
really got me the other day
and I thought I was gonna be like you in
the in the porta potty or in the in the
urinal this dude like he like we were
out in Texas and he messaged me okay man
I'm gonna be at the event tomorrow can
you kick me in the nuts and I'm like I'm
like hey I'll see you there
and he comes and he's I can tell he he
wants he wants to be famous I'm not
gonna say his look because it'll give it
away but he had a certain look and all
that
and he's like all right you're gonna
kick me I'm like no this isn't the place
what I've seen all these other like he
was like stressing and in my face about
it and I'm like bro I retired from not
kicking yeah so did I because then I
realized what it does for these people
and it's not what it does it's not been
such a bad it's not the energy I want to
put out yes now I'm not saying what it
does for people too but I think what it
what it does in their mind for them but
the dude like was like shaking I thought
he was gonna throw a swing at me and I
was like oh dude if this dude throws a
swing at me he's on the ground like he's
gonna go down and then he just like
walks away he's like well I'm coming to
L.A I'm like all right come on come to
La whatever like you know and I'm like
dude people
it's weird it's weird out there the one
guy gave you titty twisters that one
time yeah that that's an early thing I
don't like that
um but yeah it's just crazy because I've
always been like really really
careful and and like it's just always
been really important to me to to be
good the fans you know of course I'll
never turn down a photo and even when I
get the most grumpy and short like I'm
always just like put it on something and
hurry up you know like I'm still not
turning down yeah I put it on selfie
like but you know yeah
I just um I I really need to dig deep
and and uh not get grumpy because I just
don't you know no I saw a comment on an
Instagram thing says like someone's like
dude I met Stevo like don't believe
everything you read on Reddit about
somebody he was super cool to me and I'm
like no I'm like they're talking [ __ ]
about it
I have no idea I have no idea what
they're and then my next thing I think
is like dude I gotta do a Reddit AMA to
be like hey dude like Reddit Community
like I wanted to you know
it's got to ask me anything and you go
on there and like you prove that it's
you by by posting a photo saying I'm
gonna do an AMA for Reddit okay and then
they know it's gonna be you and then
they're just typing in questions and you
just type answers to the questions you
want to and the ones that are most
popular get like upvoted so like it's a
system by which they feed the most
compelling stuff to the top gotcha all
right and all I've read it works that
way so if you're AMA is you know popular
it gets upvoted up voted so you rank on
Reddit based on how much the community
is enjoying the content gotcha all right
and uh I care so much about what people
think about me that was why I'm like I
gotta [ __ ] make things right with
Reddit like I can't have people out
there being thinking saying I'm an
[ __ ] but it just it it what it kind
of leads to ultimately is that [ __ ] when
people get like famous to a point it's
just too overwhelming so yeah like
[ __ ] what do you do famous people get
branded labeled as like arrogant
[ __ ] and like I I kind of you know
like bring me home or bring me money you
know what you know you know what though
when I was a kid I used to think oh that
was shitty that that happened to the
person because I would hear and this is
even for cell phones and stuff right
that you would hear stories about fans
going up to someone they loved right and
bothering them while they're eating and
the person yelling at him and it gets
bummed and I'm like you don't like if I
came to you Scott and I was like Scott
give me a photo but you just got off the
phone and something happened or whatever
with your girlfriend or you somebody
who's something anything that now you're
in a bad mood that I'm coming into you
in your mood that you know you can't
make everybody happy you can't there's
no way I'm just putting it out there
that I want to try and yeah
the same thing and I do the same thing
but there's no way you could or else
you wouldn't be making yourself happy
right but dude like I I'm on the other
side of it and I see you guys and and
I'm like I look at the amount of photos
that you guys take and the trade-off is
like okay be famous or have I wouldn't
want to be famous because of that like
you what you do a meet and greet for 50
people twice a night there's a hundred
people you go out to Walmart or whatever
there's 20 more photos I I've seen you
be cool with
150 people and then the one person that
comes up to you like that tries to be
funny or it's like bro just you know
hurry up and take my photo that one
person will do a [ __ ] Reddit and
you're an [ __ ] but I just watched you
take 140 photos during the day 100 I
don't want to take three photos in a day
out of family function dude but but
that's what it always is it's exactly
that and that that's what I'm talking
about is the one right knucklehead that
comes up and I I don't mean to call them
not a random person or whatever yeah I
appreciate that and I love that but now
let me tell you this like after the
pandemic like uh coming back onto tour
two things that were noticeably a lot
more difficult than I ever remembered
them was going through airports and
flying on airplanes and doing meet and
greets it was just like somehow like at
the time away during the pandemic and
then coming back to meet and greets into
airplanes those two things were really
[ __ ] difficult and then now we're
performing shows in big theaters so I'm
doing like 50 people meeting great after
the show and I was I was dreading it so
I came up with this [ __ ] thing and
this is all on me I was like you know
what like if I have a marker then
everybody wants me to sign something and
it makes it take twice as long so I'm
gonna go into the meet and greet
deliberately not having a marker and if
somebody asked me to sign something I'll
play at least see oh yeah you got a
marker and they don't have one like oh
well you know I don't have one so I
guess we're not gonna sign anything and
and that was my my thing and it made the
meet and greets go by a lot quicker but
people would leave like man I wanted a
signature and it's bummed right and I
was like I don't care because I just
didn't have a marker and then I saw a
[ __ ] comment on a YouTube video where
someone says dude Stevo I got the
[ __ ] meet and greet and he like
rushed me by and I couldn't even get a
signature and I've responded to the
comment I wrote
it sounds like you didn't have a marker
I'm sorry you had a bad experience good
and then I told Lux about it and we were
at dinner we were on a date and I'm like
I saw the comment while I was in the
[ __ ] bathroom and uh and she's like
babe he gotta [ __ ] be cooler this is
people think it's important they're
meeting you and I'm like you know what
like [ __ ] Alex is right you know and
and I'm just saying from my perspective
seeing that [ __ ] comment and my
[ __ ] response to it like I [ __ ]
it bothered me all night I'm like [ __ ]
there's this person out there that's
[ __ ] that I bummed out and that and
and I decided then and there that I
would rather be [ __ ] miserable
inconvenienced by like a [ __ ] meet
and greet that takes way too long and
make sure every person leaves completely
[ __ ] happy then be inconvenienced and
miserable by a whole night of just
[ __ ] feeling shitty about a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh I see what you're saying yeah so
now I'm now I'm deliberately leaning
into it to make sure everybody leaves
[ __ ] like they [ __ ] we're special
and [ __ ] let's say you go ahead and
do all that and you're making everybody
happy then you have the [ __ ] last
person in line or the middle person line
that's like hey can you make a video for
my niece she's not here yeah
when people would ask you when people
ask me make a video I would I would like
sometimes like kind of funny and
sometimes like to strip it I'd say oh I
see what you're saying I'm not dealing
with enough people in person
now you're now you're introducing third
party people just so that I can have to
[ __ ] deal with more [ __ ] people
dude now you're making me tired you're
making me talk to people who aren't even
here because I'm not [ __ ] working
hard enough for you is that right I mean
it's crazy and now you know what I've
done I do every [ __ ] video everybody
asks for it no questions same place
let me see on behalf of you guys because
like the people listening are probably
gonna say they're always going to find
something to say like oh well they're
complaint about being famous it's like
look it I'm not famous I travel with
Steve I've been with we man I've been
with all those guys they I've seen Steve
in in probably take
90 000 photos without a [ __ ] you know
what I mean and anybody in that
situation you would not be able to
handle the amount of [ __ ] photos that
they take with a good attitude so it's
like before anybody's like oh you know
you're just so ungrateful it's not like
that at all I've seen them bend over
[ __ ] backwards I've seen you guys
somebody complains about oh I have this
niece with you will [ __ ] send them
money or a flight without even anybody
even [ __ ] like all I want to do a
video with Steve where I'm like hey
let's go pay for somebody's rent and
you're like I would never do that on
camera and you'll go ahead and do it off
the camera so it's like the amount of
things that people see off the camera
it's like yeah it always hurts me when
people do good deeds back in for a video
I [ __ ] hate that dude I think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome as
mine new book a hard kick in the nuts
what I've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions my first books Five
star rated on Amazon and I have no doubt
this one will be too so get the
autograph copy right now at stevo.com
yeah dude